I dodged Stefan comma is head of
domestic intelligence in the Eastern
German state of Julian about his agency
is called the office for the protection
of the Constitution welcome to being in
hats it's become true window hello how
do you think well compatible you
interview it's good to have you with us
before talking about your position I'd
like to introduce you to our viewers you
were born in nineteen sixty eight in the
region of Z gallant you converted to
Judaism as an adult what led you to
Judaism l'album convex yet besides eat
some good food if you had seen me long
after Zuko's I was searching for myself
for a long time I got into other
religions but at the request of my
parents I was never baptized so I never
belonged to a faithful I discovered my
affinity my love for Judaism relatively
late and wants it to be part of the
Jewish people Uncas Amish these tires
this musician for because we have mm-hmm
mistake you but converting to Judaism is
not only a matter of signing a piece of
paper it's a big commitment oh did you
struggle with the decision vodice frizzy
and want me design and trying to hang in
mesquite the ignition please note it's
not about learning questions and answers
by heart it's not just about the fact
it's more of an inner decision with a
conviction those who think you just need
to know facts to belong are wrong lova
guilty but as far as learning the facts
goes it wasn't I didn't make it easy for
myself or the rabbis who studied with me
and accompanied me on my way but I did
it out of conviction in the old people
and the whole heartedly still midam
hudson devices on mm-hmm and your wife
is a Jewish American did she influenced
your decision mentalist and a whole
luggage p 90 13 easton no she didn't
because i had already made my decision
to convert to Judaism before before even
meeting her to flash on foot so before
we was gettin it on film mm-hmm it
sounds easy you grew up without a
religion and chose freely to become
Jewish what about your children the King
doesn't you dish my mind if all their
Jewish because my wife is Jewish
according to Jewish laws of decision so
they don't have to decide no man avatar
fight not to lose initiative that
doesn't mean that they
talk about religion with us or arguing
you in this school to you know it's not
always easy to bring them up so that
they also develop an affinity for the
religion we haven't so doesn't does
he'll find it soon item to delhi lead
you on film spy doesn't in 2004 you
became Secretary General of the Central
Council of Jews in Germany was your
conversion to Judaism a prerequisite or
had you already decided to convert
treatise the FA's nickiheppell fool no
it wasn't I'd already worked for an
American Jewish organization and when
Charlotte a new block told me in the
fall of nineteen ninety-eight that my
next post would be personal advisor to
Ignatz boobies the fact that I wasn't
formally a Jew played no role can you to
be another two minutes for America and
you would it was a decision based on
affinity I know ya soon I homes and
tried on ignites boobis felt the same
way but i must say that both of them
supported and encouraged me in my
conversion when there were setbacks
function which playing a good buddy but
with the white that's among his mind's
email in retrospect what do you think
your most important task was as
secretary-general of the Council of Jews
that's the sign the guns for you to get
fired I know it's a tough question
because I had a variety of tasks I
wasn't originally meant to become
Secretary General I started out as
ignites boobis personal advisor by then
i worked with the next president and
became secretary general nothing was
planned i'm optimistic it was important
for me to have an impact on the inner
workings of the community and to play a
small part and giving it more
self-confidence over those insolence
women didn't i think that was a success
the mind off it some such commands on
balloon dammit back then you wanted to
abolish the intelligence service you now
lead and now okay that's can sign the
60th nothing let's say the project is
still open but the fact that there are
plans now to reform the agency shows
that politicians have understood
something the political important steps
have been made at least a good reforms
but i did call for the office to be
abolished at the height of the debate
over how the murders of the right-wing
terror cell the NS you could have gone
unnoticed it was impossible to simply
write off the mistakes revealed at the
time
there have been scandals before then and
the way the agencies were set up meant
they weren't fit for the future hamza
dammit Skylar songs for the to confer
out the mote band does the NSU murderers
were from chewing it meant the office
for the protection of the Constitution
there had no idea what was going on what
was your judgment of the office at the
time Saudis outside you buddies in 4,000
foot stammers nine Clavis hotel
photography gear across the board not
only at the office for the protection of
the Constitution we didn't it soon
became clear that the police the
judiciary and the politicians had failed
miserably become in retrospect I think
we all have to take a good look at
ourselves along because nobody really
realized the scale of in front of guns
are nonetheless it means that there have
to be consequences the committee's have
revealed clear deficits and we are now
working on remedies so did Simba's in
see you've been head of this office
since December you've said that friends
questioned your state of mind when you
took the job why did you take the offer
what's him go on this ship in sweats
initiative well I'm not the type to sign
up for a lost cause in butter again in
fact decided very quickly to take a
clear stand against all the problems
they set up a committee very early on to
investigate everything much to the
annoyance of the other offices and put
their cards on the table so it was very
promising that the affinity of entering
in is now moving ahead fast with the
reform project many of the other offices
are looking to us with suspicion but
they're also curious to see how we cope
with this project aqua and I find being
involved in that quite exciting editing
on da by mid-summer on finish under
their son died of carbon dust Victor but
i'm also very curious what were the
first steps that you took come on Naboo
diez modality well it was the state
government of course that took the first
steps there were concrete reforms in the
structure in the legal and parliamentary
oversight they set up a controller with
new employees but i always said roll the
best safety measures won't help if the
people who work there don't have the
right attitude and dimensioned many of
the employees
did have the right attitude but there
was a lack of leadership now I'm here
but as the old adage goes one swallow
does not a summer make a mock no kind
food so we have to get things moving
because the fight against the current
threat must continue is not philosopher
des landes legen Julian's the tooling
and authorities don't want to create new
jobs at your office unlike other state
governments in Germany you're there now
and have to deal with those who fail to
clean it up can that work I was Miss
Candis foots onion was this fearlessness
kb2 it's difficult I admit but I'm not
only working with people who fail to
clean things up there have been a lot of
changes in snack stand I was surprised
to find many young and motivated
employees who are well aware of their
responsibilities some have had to
unfairly endure criticism and ridicule
in recent years so I need to remote of
ate them but you're right I'd have liked
to take on new personnel and we really
need them but I've become very modest in
that respect I'm just grateful we
haven't seen any cuts from fooled us
when they could coax thought isn't and
the head of the chillin in office for
the protection of the Constitution is
supposed to be a qualified judge you
studied law but didn't finish is this an
issue and this isn't probably you think
in itasca sighs I don't think so finds
oil firstly it's considered preferable
but not mandatory the fact is I'm
surrounded by a number of experienced
and fully qualified lawyers who've
worked as public prosecutors I think
adding someone like me study educational
science brings another aspect to the job
in any case it was fully qualified
lawyers who made this mess in the first
place movie about anything bored yeah
that's a nice NSU was not the NPD they
weren't only right-wing extremists they
were right-wing terrorists he'll listen
as the chapter of right-wing terrorism
ended with the trial in Munich or are
there new terrorists at work scenes e na
hoga embarrassment the heights the
essence globe is des portes law if
you're not well firstly the trial is
still continuing and secondly we still
have committees investigating other
things I don't believe we've finished
investigating the mistakes
that were made back then and the changes
that need to be made but I would also
say the trial into banning the far right
NPD party or other such trials won't
solve this problem I've always said you
can't van far-right thinking but you do
need to fight it politically him from
Muslim but what we're seeing today in
altering it and else are is that
right-wing terrorist structures are on
the increase we now have other groups
that are at least as bad as the NSU and
we need to be vigilant Z as a person you
could be so to speak the double-target
of right-wing terrorists you practice
the Jewish faith and on top of that your
head of domestic intelligence you used
to carry a weapon do you still we don't
first and as beneath I'm not at liberty
to talk about security measures but I
feel safe and well protected although
there's of course no absolute safety
policy I'm not to but you're right for
many I'm a double source of evil and
that's the way it should be people of a
right-wing extremist persuasion should
know that I intend to put things
straight and up the pressure on them God
we can be I don't finding the octant Oh
Kevin via Delft Jesus same people do
slender Germany states including
cheering and want to stamp out
right-wing extremism or at least start
by banning the NPD party that must be
worrying to you if the party goes
underground it will be more difficult
for you this isn't special ed it's a
double-edged sword if the constitutional
court bans the NPD party which is my
hope for all concerned then obviously
that sends a signal to everyone that
this kind of party and all that it
represents has no place in our political
landscape but as you rightly point out
these structures won't then disappear
they will just be modified which makes
our lives in the intelligence services
more difficult we both but that isn't
the problem will be able to resolve that
ankle boot of the unknowns I don't a
bite of the unknowns right and thus is
nice toss problem except owes me a
losing can see Sean kind of country
you're not afraid of conflict as your CV
shows you had an altercation with the
Jewish historian Misha a dwarf song who
wrote and I quote does the convert comma
want to prove to us were born as Jews
that he's the better ones did that hurt
tivity death for wolf yep if Nick you up
it didn't bother me I've heard those
kinds of accusations against conference
before my and will no doubt there are
converts who try to be better Jews but
my conscience is clear I've proven in my
life that I follow my own path so the
accusations just bounce off so close to
end our interview mr. comma we always
have three unfinished statements that we
ask our guests to complete if the
whistleblower Edward Snowden wanted to
seek asylum at a Berlin synagogue I
would be as usual invited and vh don't
favor from Italy did I was in the CD on
the ftp and now the SPD party the left
party is in power enjoying it for me the
left party is not an alternative many
things my most pressing task enduring in
is for to restore trust trust in
politicians but also in the people of
Turin and Beyond step Stefan comma
thanks for talking to us thank you